some of the best films are subjective
meaning their stories can be interpreted
a number of different ways depending on
the viewers own experiences but an
excessively ambiguous ending or a sudden
shift in tone can leave audiences
scratching their heads and confusion
don't worry we're here to explain some
of the most baffling movie endings that
don't mean exactly what you think they
do
beware however there are spoilers ahead
in bruges in this darkly comic morality
tale assassins ray and Ken are sent to
Bruges to lay low after a hit gone wrong
by the end of the film half the cast is
dead and Ray is being carried away to an
ambulance pondering the nature of
morality and he'll viewers are
ultimately left to wonder whether or not
he survived the film's bloody climax in
one reading of the film however this
question doesn't matter because Ray is
wait for it already in purgatory earlier
in the film Ken takes ray on an art
store of Bruges whereupon the 2-view
hieronymus Bosch's the Last Judgement
painting it's the one segment of the
tour that ray actually seems invested in
and it sparks a conversation about
purgatory around which ray describes as
kind of a scene between anyone
you weren't really but you weren't all
that great either the final scene of the
movie mirrors bashas painting as a
fatally wounded ray looks up at
mysterious animal faced creatures really
just actors in costume while he wonders
what punishments await him he thinks
Bruges is hell but maybe it's just a
place for people not quite bad enough
for the real thing
Total Recall 1990s mind-bending Total
Recall has become a cult classic in the
decades since its release adapted from
sci-fi author philip k dick short story
we can remember it for you wholesale the
film centers around Douglas Quaid a
construction worker from the year 2084
though Quaid may or may not also be a
secret agent with memory loss and a
rebel involved in war on Mars the film
continually encourages audiences to
question the reality of what they're
watching
are you actually seeing Quaid finish his
secret mission or is this part of the
recall procedure one moment near the end
of the film seems to suggest most of the
film took place in his noggin early in
the movie before the recall procedure
has started a lab tech reading Quaid's
Dreams notes that they include a
sky on Mars while the similarities
between the character milena and the
woman in quoits dreams can be explained
away by his buried memories the lab
techs are clearly surprised by his
conception of a Mars with a blue sky
when the movie ends with Quaid and
Molina looking over the Martian sky
newly blue from oxygen after saving the
planet
it's the biggest clue to the viewer that
they're watching a dream get out the
story of Chris a black man meeting his
white girlfriend's parents for the first
time get out borders on dark comedy at
times but the genre-bending flick goes
full horror when the family's chilling
secret comes to light by the end of the
movie Chris has escaped the grounds of
the Armitage mansion with his friend rod
after killing the family and setting
their secret brain swapping laboratory
ablaze the end of the movie sees rod
telling Chris that he can consider this
situation handled but Chris doesn't
respond to rod instead he stares
dejectedly into the dashboard as they
drive away leaving his girlfriend rose
to die in the street behind them while
it's cathartic to see the hero of the
film survive defeat the villains and
drive off with his friend the ending is
a bit darker than people realize Chris
knows the situation isn't handled Logan
a victim of the procedure shown earlier
in the film is still being
mind-controlled and a few dozen old
white Gentry are still stealing black
bodies and minds in the alternate ending
these tragic realities are made much
more explicit Chris winds up in jail for
the murder of the Armitage family with
no way to prove his innocence or expose
their crimes
he tells rod that at least he stopped it
as he's led to a cell where he's
surrounded by other black men in both
endings racism isn't vanquished just
because Chris is able to defeat the rich
Body Snatchers they were just one
particularly repugnant example of a
systemic and very real horror Fargo
Fargo ranks among the most
straightforward of the Coen Brothers
films it's the story of a small-town
crime a greedy little man with a massive
ego and a witty sheriff with a good
heart still viewers are more likely to
remember Steve Buscemi performance and
his gruesome disposal in the wood
chipper then the movies quiet touching
ending in the film's final scene sheriff
Marge has shown lain in bed with her
husband norm who laments that his
Mallard painting was passed over for the
first class stamp contest Margie says
she's proud of him adding heck norm you
know we're doing pretty good
the subtle ending completely
encapsulates the core themes of the
movie refuting the naked greed of nearly
every other character from Jerry whose
ambitions lead to the deaths of nearly
half a dozen people - Mike's desperate
desire for Marge to believe that his
life is more interesting and tragic than
it seems the characters in Fargo so
chaos when they focus on what they want
rather than what they have Marge's
confirmation of the good life she and
her husband have built together changes
the movie from a comedy drama into a
morality play reminding the audience to
be grateful for what they have shutter
island' shutter island' the Martin
Scorsese adaptation of the novel of the
same name is a period thriller boasting
a murderer's row of talent including
Leonardo DiCaprio Mark Ruffalo and Ben
Kingsley in 1954 US Marshal Teddy
Daniels investigates an insane asylum
following the escape of notorious
murderer Andrew ladis while dealing with
the suspicious dr. Cawley and the
disappearance of his partner Chuck the
central twist of the movie drew most of
the audience's attention basically Teddy
Daniels is actually Andrew ladis acting
out a fantasy to restore his memories
following the murder of his wife after
she drowned their children years ago but
it was the enigmatic final line of the
movie that has confused audiences well
beyond the credits Teddy seemingly
regressed back to his original delusion
that he is a u.s. marshal asks Chuck
which would be worse
to live is a monster what a die is a
good man according to Scorsese
psychiatric advisor on the film James
Gilligan the line represents Teddy
faking his own regression choosing this
path to atone for the murder of his wife
the last moments of the film can be
interpreted as if teddy were actually
saying I feel too guilty to go on living
I'm not going to actually end my life
but I'm going to vicariously do it by
handing myself over to these people who
are going to lobotomize me thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]